JOANNE STUBBE: We spend a
lot of time looking at--
all proteins are made from
amino acid building blocks.
And so one question I get,
and students hate this,
is, why do I need to know?
I make them memorize the side
chains of the amino acids.
Why do I do that?
Because the side chains
of the amino acids
are the key to the way all
the catalysts in your body
function.
A catalyst simply
enhances the rate
of conversion of
some small molecule
into some other small
molecule, and it
can enhance the rate
of the interconversion
by 10 to the 15th fold.
So if you didn't
have that catalyst,
you couldn't do anything.
So amino acid side chains
play a key role in catalysis.
So thinking about the
chemical properties
of the amino acid side chains
is key to understanding
all the transformations
in your body.
So, what is the
pKa of imidazole?
You remember that?
Huh?
GUEST SPEAKER: I don't.
I don't.
JOANNE STUBBE: How can
you not remember that?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyhow, the pKa of imidazole
is close to seven, OK.
So those physiological--
everything in the body
is controlled.
The pH has to be controlled.
And so that means that you can
protonate or deprotonate it.
So knowing that is key to
thinking about how the chemical
reaction is going to work.
The amino acid side chains now--
everybody thought there
were 22 amino acids.
But now we know almost
all these amino acids can
be modified once they
get into the protein,
so that's called
post-transational modification.
So now we have, probably,
another 250 modifications.
And one of the modifications
that is essential,
not for the catalysis
part of proteins,
but for the structural
is hydroxylation of
the amino acid proline.
So if you don't
hydroxylate proline,
then you can't make this
molecule called collagen.
And collagen is a
structural protein.
It's 25% of all
humans' protein, OK.
And it's found extracellularly.
Gram per gram it has
the strength of steel.
It has very complicated
biosynthetic pathway.
It has amazing tensile strength.
It's found in cartilage
and teeth and bone.
And a key component of collagen
is this hydroxylated proline.
Because without it, you can't
form the actual collagen
structure.
So collagen is this
long-- most proteins,
if you look at the structures,
they look like little balls.
They're globular.
But collagen is a fibrillar
protein, so it's very long.
it's probably the
longest protein, too.
It's 3,000 angstroms long.
And it has three chains
initially, and they
they're left-handed sort of
helixes but not real helixes,
and they have to wind
around each other
to form a right-handed helix.
This all happens
inside the cell, then
somehow has to get to
the outside of the cell.
People are studying that now.
And then it forms
additional fibrils,
and they become insoluble.
And that provides the strength--
the extracellular structures
provide the strength that
maintain the cell's shape
and viability of the cell.
And a key component of all that
is hydroxylation of proline.
And how did they find that?
This goes back to,
again, misregulation.
So, in the 1600s,
or whenever they
used to sail the ocean
blue with no food,
they didn't have
enough vitamin C.
So they didn't have
any citrus fruit.
So vitamin C has the
vitamin ascorbate,
and ascorbate plays a
key role in the chemistry
of allowing the proline
to become hydroxylated.
So it turns out,
to get the proline
to be hydroyxlated,
you use, again,
metal catalyzed reactions.
So here's iron-2.
And if that iron-2
reacts with oxygen,
if it gets oxidized with
iron-3, it can't react.
So the function
of this vitamin is
to keep the iron-2
in the reduced state.
So there's an example.
People study that.
Took them many,
many, many years,
like 200 years later,
when they really
understand the details of
how this post-translational
modification actually occurs.
And we understand a lot
about that chemistry now.
And this was the first one of
these modifications discovered,
and now they're finding this
modification everywhere.
So lots of amino acids turn out
to be hydroxylated, not just
proline.
So these modified
amino acids now,
because the technology we
have is so mind boggling,
we can find a needle
in a haystack.
Whereas in the
beginning we were just
trying to figure out what
the amino acids were,
now we have very, very
sensitive analytical methods
which allow us to see all
of these modifications.
Then the key question
is, what is the function
of the modification?
And that's not so easy
in terms of thinking
about regulation, anyhow.
And that's the focus of a lot
of people's efforts right now.